all right another big company from
silicon valley is saying goodbye to
silicon valley not entirely but euler
packard enterprises indicating it's
going to move a lot of its operations to
houston
texas uh sam ricardo joins us right now
the mayor of san jose has been doing his
best to stop this sort of thing but it
has happened
yet again mayor very good to have you
what do you make of this now
um it looks like reading from
hewlett-packard enterprises comments on
this that it's not abandoning your area
but it certainly is cutting down uh its
presence
in your area does it alarm you
well certainly it's a wake-up call for
all of us neil
and uh the good news is here in the city
of san jose they're actually adding
hundreds of employees because they're
consolidating their operations here in
silicon valley in my city
but we are seeing the headquarters move
and we know that this is a story
uh we've seen before that certainly
for the kind of talent that you really
need to find in silicon valley
uh that heavily specialize if it's
around artificial intelligence or
engineering or software you'll find it
in silicon valley and folks will want to
locate here
but if you're looking to expand
operations for accountants or lawyers or
administrative assistants
uh you can do that in a lot of other
places for a lot less and
we've got to do more to make this region
and this state
more affordable um you've been trying to
address that uh you know you were
re-elected in 2018 but with
more than 70 uh what five percent of the
vote at the time
and largely by taking on you know unions
and entrenched
pension-funded organizations where you
just wanted to ease back on those
obligations because they're a good
reason
why san jose and other areas across the
country that have similar issues
are are so pricey and actually being
priced out and having companies move
but that apparently wasn't isn't enough
so what does the state have to do
well the biggest challenge i think we
all have is with housing costs it makes
it so expensive to live here obviously
companies need to pay a lot just to keep
people here
and there's a lot more we need to do to
ramp up production uh
we can certainly get some of the red
tape out of the way uh and i appreciate
some recent efforts of the governor for
example
to be able to uh for example wave sql
and the construction of affordable
housing we need for
homeless residents for example that
enabled us to build three separate
developments in four months rather than
four years
you know those are the kinds of things
we need to do mostly is just getting out
of the way
but also we need to be more innovative
and how we're building housing we're
using a lot of
different technologies for example
prefab and modular housing and that
takes
local bureaucracies to be able to be
nimble to enable to permit those kinds
of things make sure they're safe but
obviously
still allow the innovation so housing is
really a core of it but we know there's
a lot
else going on it's taxes it's regulation
it's a lot of issues
where i think we just need to be very
cognizant in california we've been
taking
it for granted for too long that tech
employers want to be here
uh that won't happen forever
did you offer an alternative deal to
stop euler packard enterprise for making
this move or did they say our minds made
up we're building this big facility in
houston we're going there
no you know i've been very clear that we
don't want to offer
companies deals of any kind uh when
amazon was announcing its
beauty contest for the move its
headquarters i wrote an op-ed in the
in the wall street journal saying thanks
but we're not giving you any money i
don't believe in giving taxpayer money
to
to companies and hpe never asked for to
their credit they've been
completely above board with us uh i
understood
uh clearly why they'd be going to
houston they have a lot of operations
already there and a lot of employees
but for those headquarters operations
you don't necessarily need the top
technical talent they can keep all that
here in silicon valley
and they can hire elsewhere you know you
think it's about more than taxes though
and the cost of living okay i know
you've apologized for this
uh incident where you joined your family
for thanksgiving it was quite a large
gathering or larger maybe than even you
expect as suspected
but it came at a time with a number of
other top politicians
mostly democrats hate to say that to you
uh
did one thing and and and and practiced
another
uh do you think that people look at that
mayor and say
the guy's a hypocrite sure i
i recognize uh folks will come to those
kinds of conclusions and i made a
mistake and i own it
and i certainly should have been more
astute about
the specifics of the regulations i knew
that there were advisories and i
simply should have been more astute to
it and
you know i i as as i learned in the
media reported that i was at home
we immediately disclosed no actually i
was at my parents house and
that's how all this came out uh so i i
going hard and certainly i'm going to do
better you when you entered your
your your relative's house did you
notice oh wow there's a big crowd here
on and and i'm the mayor of san jose and
i've just been telling my
constituents keep it small keep it
limited did you
did you think no no i can't claim to
have been to a virgin
the reality is i've i've got a big
family i'm one of five kids and so
typically thanksgiving for us is 25
people we actually had
uh eight adults dining at the same time
uh
and the problem was under the state
rules you can only have three households
and so we had too many households there
uh even though all of us
many of us have been dining together uh
every week uh simply the rules have
changed obviously as
we've gone into deeper into the this
challenging period of high infection
spread
and i should have known better i should
have done better
well unlike a lot of other politicians
did the exact same thing
um you got ahead of it you apologized
for it i did so again
i have more did maybe easier to move on
mayor thank you very very much good
having you
be well let's see how this whole
hewlett-packard thing goes